as he watched derrick chauvin kneel on
george floyd's increasingly lifeless
body
donald williams called the police to
report on the police
at some point did you make a 9-1-1 call
that is correct i did call the police on
the police
and why did you do that because
i believe i witnessed a murder
williams testifying for a second time on
day two of the high profile civil rights
trial can be heard on bystander video
calling out two officers to stop the man
ain't moved yet bro
the man ain't moved yet bro the teen who
took that viral video of floyd beneath
the knee of former minneapolis police
officer chauvin
testifying off camera because of her age
says floyd seemed to know he was dying
it's been nice i stayed up
apologizing
and apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more and
not physically interacting and
not saving his life but it's like
it's not what i should have done it's
what he should have done
she was followed by her nine-year-old
cousin i was sad
and kind of mad and tell us why were you
saying that
cause it felt like he was stopping his
breathing
and it is kind of like hurting him
she watched she said as paramedics had
to push chauvin off an
unmoving floyd prosecutors use the
witness video
to show jurors that what plays out on
the video
is really all they need to know in the
words of one prosecutor
you can believe your eyes the defense
seems to be building a case that the
officers felt they couldn't move
george floyd because of what they
perceived as a growing
hostile and unruly mob around them
do you recall saying i dare you to touch
me like that
i swear i'll slap the out of both of you
yeah i didn't i meant it
right so again sir it's fair to say that
you grew angrier and angrier no i
grew professional and professional i
stayed in my body
you can't pay me out to be angry
prosecutors are expected to wrap their
testimony sometime next week
that's when defense lawyers will present
their case possibly including the
testimony of the officer
chauvin is the one on trial but for many
inside and outside the courtroom
what's on the docket is racial justice
in america
john hendren al jazeera minneapolis a
firefighter who was off duty at the time
of the incident that led to floyd's
death also testified on tuesday
genevieve hansen
described how officers refused to let
her intervene
in my memory i offered to what kind of
walk them through it or
or told them if he doesn't have a pulse
you need to start compressions
and that wasn't done either is this
are these things that you wanted to do
it would have
it's what i would have done for anybody
when you couldn't do that how did that
make you feel
totally distressed were you frustrated
yes
foreign